so my name is Stefan 30 and I'm the
visual effects supervisor on Doctor
Strange what does being a visual effects
supervisor mean in general in the film
world well I'm in charge of delivering
all the visual effects for the film so
in general it means that I'm gonna be
here from the very beginning to talk
with the director and establish a plan
and what we want to do for the film and
then attend the shoot and work on the
film in post-production to avoid to the
end to delivery and what was the most
exciting or the exciting part about
working on a project like Doctor Strange
you've worked on a lot of big big movies
before but yeah pair to those how's this
different well it was I mean I started
dr. strange just after I finished
guardians of the galaxy for Marvel
already so I you know it was kind of a
new challenge because it's a brand new
you know story and ideas and new
characters so that was the interesting
thing and it's going in a place where
Marvel has not gone before so that was
really really interesting for me when
you say it hasn't gone to it's going to
a new place or it's gotten where it
hasn't gone yet or what does that mean
what it's I mean we're you know going
into the magical side of the Marvel
Universe and also exploring a new
dimension so it's it's very exciting in
that sense it's like things that they've
never played before is so and these
characters are really interesting in the
idea of Marvel Universe they're bringing
a new fully new idea a new branch of the
story so it's it's very exciting in that
sense so here at IMAX you know we take
great measure to deliver a quality
picture immersive sound what does that
mean to you can you talk a little bit
about your relationship with I'm an IMAX
well I've always been super interested
by IMAX you know the quality of the
footage that comes out and you know what
we can do with it we had already
explored that a little bit on on
guardians but on this one because we
used the new cameras which are shooting
much higher resolution the re 65 we had
been thinking about IMAX even more so
that was really something that we were
looking for from the beginning and you
know one of the things that we always
say is that we want to deliver
you know to you guys the filmmakers into
audiences what the filmmakers intended
yes you know because you can watch it on
so many different formats yeah stuff can
you talk about what what that means to
an audience well I mean it's fishing in
a film like books of strange where we're
you know we're exploring new dimensions
and we're really going big on like New
York and Hong Kong where you know it's
like big scale sequences I think having
the extra size of the screen and the
resolution and all the sound coming with
it I think it's way more immersive for
the for the audience so in that sense
getting the the IMAX release is really
exciting for us and we have about 60
minutes or more of the film that is in
IMAX and for these 60 minutes were going
into a bigger format as well you know
the the film is formatted for 200 but
for these special sequences were going
to the full IMAX format which is 1.9 and
we've you know put extra care into
adding some extra things top and bottom
of the frame and making sure that there
is more to the experience when you go to
IMAX so in that sense it was it was
quite exciting for us we're gonna come
back around to that yeah just kind of to
go back a little bit what was the
process like of interpreting one of
Marvel's like trickiest sort of more
abstract economic books and bringing it
to the big screen what was that process
I mean it started a long time ago like
two years ago when when I started on the
film in September 2014 I scott
derrickson the director had already
started to gather a lot of images and
references from the comics and from you
know films and photographs and paintings
you know so we started to look at what
we could start from to create our worlds
Hollywood which the production designer
came to LA as well and we did a lot of
brainstorming together with Scott and
the people at Marvel to try and
establish and define what what the world
of Doctor Strange would be so that
started very early in the process and we
kind of worked hand-in-hand with Scott
and the script writers to establish that
world and the rules of the magic and all
that stuff so then we went into previous
which is a huge part of the process
because we're kind of defining the movie
in a dynamic way and then you know
breaking down the effects and all the
way you know the different ways to shoot
it because it's a very challenging film
to shoot very technical in a way in
order to deliver the vision that's got
add for the film so that was you know
before the shoot and then the shooting
happened and it's very very you know a
lot of different setups too to create
all these action sequences and then
we're going to post and we work with all
the vendors that we had we had four main
vendors in the film and in order to
create all these effects so it's it's a
it's a multi-step process that goes from
the very inception beginning and
creation of the other world to the
delivery you know two years later
actually when it comes to approaching
the design you know specific details
yeah this world can you talk a little
bit about you know the approach and sort
of in detail what those elements were
what was new to the world
well I mean we try to be very faithful
to the material the original material
from from the comics in that sense you
know Scott had very specific views on
how the world should look like it was
referring a lot to the work of Steve
Ditko we did all the Marvel comics in
the 60s and 70s for Doctor Strange and
we wanted to keep the psychedelic aspect
of the work that was done in this time
so it was a lot to do with creating this
world with colors and you know
saturation and the space how it how big
it is we travel through these dimensions
and all that stuff so we really looked
at that and then we elaborated it you
know from our perspective in 21st
century so using our the tools that we
have now to create all these world in 3d
and being able to fly through them and
explore all that all these worlds so it
was a kind of an interpretation of what
was on the page a long time ago and
trying to make it fresh and new for
today
awesome yeah why is dr. strange the type
of film that demands to be in that
special IMAX format well I think there's
so you know the film is very visual
because we're trying to do a lot of
visual storytelling you know because all
these magic and all these worlds that
we're exploring are being told visually
through the film so in that sense and
because of the scale of the film and the
scale of the magic in the film I feel
like I'm accidently the right format for
it because it gives us the extra space
and the extra immersion for the audience
to go into the film and really be taken
by it and I think the IMAX is the right
format to it and three IMAX is even
better yeah we often talk about sort of
the immersive quality that IMAX adds new
film you know from the curved screen
yeah extra and like and even the seating
is like a little further huh do you want
to talk a little bit about why those
aspects of well I mean I've you know we
work on the film in a normal format you
know we just look at it in normal
screens and then I did the first few
viewings in IMAX and I was like blown
away to be honest because even for me it
was like rediscovering the film because
you know we don't we don't look at it in
IMAX until we're really getting into the
IMAX process even though we think about
it and we design the shots this way
we're like when I was sitting for the
first time in the IMAX theater looking
at it in IMAX even for me it was like oh
wow you know so yeah I think it's truly
it's even even for me it was like a to
rediscovery of the film because looking
at it with such a big screen and being
so immersed into it it's like you know
it's like a new experience even even as
you know I've worked at it for two years
and looking at the images that we have
shot and the images that we have created
was such in a blew me away
really it did and I was very you know
moved by it in some ways when I saw it
the first time when you saw it that big
were there any moments when you were
like oh that means like a little bit
work well we're very careful about you
know we we scrutinize everything as we
do it so and we knew that we're going
for IMAX so all the you know all the
details we're putting into the image are
very well defined and we're trying to be
as clean as we can obviously there was a
few tweaks that we wanted to do so we've
been very careful about these but most
of the time things kind of held up
pretty well especially with the kind of
cameras we've been using to shoot the
film can you sort of give an explanation
sort of a basic explanation of what it
means to change the aspect ratio from
two for o to 1/9 well I mean that's
that's an idea that we started to play
with them on guardians and Evan Jacobs
our 3d supervisor has been playing with
that quite a lot in the last few Marvel
films and I think it's just it's really
about making it more immersive you know
the two I love the 2/4 format that's the
format of choice for me and we did most
of the film like that but I think for
the action sequences and for the kind of
you know effects that we're doing with
the environment and the different places
were going to and the cities were going
to I think 1.9 format which is the IMAX
format just makes things bigger and more
immersive as well so I think even though
you don't always notice it as you watch
the movie I think deep down within your
brain it does create something where you
feel like you're into the film more and
with the 3d it's just really really
special yeah Scott the director talks
about how he purposefully chose to sort
of go from that she went to the other
instead of really doing the whole thing
and yeah yeah can you talk about what
kind of impact well it's in the end it's
a creative decision you know we're not
doing it just because we can do it we're
just doing it because it brings
something special to the film and I
think in that sense we've been very
cautious about the moments where we
wanted to stay into Thoreau and the
moments when we actually go to 1.9
there's a big example of that is there's
a scene at the beginning of a film which
is called we call the magic mystery tour
where dr. strange is pushed into all
these dimensions by the ancient one and
that's the you know
one of the first time in the film where
we actually go to 1.9 and the experience
is very different because you you're
travelling through all these space and
all these dimensions and it's it's it
just you know it makes it bigger and
more immersive definitely were there any
unique or innovative techniques that you
sort of had to create or discover while
working on this film well I mean there's
there's a lot of things that we've been
you know doing R&D on on the film on
many levels like from a creative point
of view doing some R&D on how to praying
the world of optical illusion and usher
and kaleidoscopic stuff to the screen
and making sense of it all the
distortion of the buildings in the
cities and all that stuff to a huge
scale so definitely there's a creative
side of it there's also a very technical
side of it in terms of the way we're
shooting stuff the use of special rigs
and and motion control cameras and in a
in a in a way that was allowing us to
keep the action going and and you know
all the things that we've been doing for
the film there's lots of aspects in
terms of R&D that you know I'm not going
to go in details on but there's there's
a lot of things that we've done but I
think that the biggest challenge of the
film is not so much from a technical
point of view but it's from a creative
point of view trying to make sure that
the visual effects which are sometimes
overwhelming are here to help the story
and bring it up you know so it's it's
about finding the right level of
cohesion between the storytelling and
the characters and making sure that they
don't get overwhelmed by the visuals so
it's finding that balance and the the
R&D that we've put into the film was
mostly about creative R&D I would say
yeah I think the film does a very good
job of sort of keeping you there with
the characters you don't feel like
you're sort of lost even though they're
yes like so much I feel much happens
exactly were there any particular scenes
that were challenging to produce a lot
of it was challenging actually again in
different ways you know if you look at
the challenge the creative challenge of
doing the magic mist
at the beginning of the film which is a
big like psychedelic travel through the
worlds and dimensions and you know
there's lots of homage to 2001 and tons
of other things and so that's a cool one
creative challenge in its own you know
it's a little film within the film and
then we've got the big action sequences
like New York where we had to build you
know a full digital version of New York
and bend it in many different ways and
and make it interesting throughout the
chase and make it meaningful as well so
that was a big challenge in terms of the
amount of work that it requested and
then we have Hong Kong where we had to
play around with time manipulation
simulation of destructions going
backwards shooting that sequence was
very hard it was at night we shot it for
23 days because it was very complex to
shoot with all these different passes of
people going forward the background
going backwards at different time you
know frame rates it's all very complex
and you know it takes a lot of planning
and working out the solutions to shoot
these things and then accomplish them in
post so all of the sequences at their
own little challenge and I would say
every shot had their own challenge and
you know we're bringing a new magic to
the world as well so it's all very
changing in many different ways is there
any particular scene or shot or location
or sequence that you're especially proud
of and excited for people to experience
well they're all my babies so it's
difficult to choose but I would say I
like Hong Kong because it's kind of
special you know it's good that
backwards destruction feel which i think
is actually a new thing in a blockbuster
movie usually in you know in this kind
of movies we end up destroying half of
the world right and now if you look at
it at the end of Doctor Strange we've
not destroyed anything we've actually
rebuilt Hong Kong it was destroyed and
we're going backwards and so we're
taking the whole idea of a blockbuster
film but putting it upside down which i
think is pretty clever actually so I
think I'm pretty proud of that you know
of the
idea and the way we've done it on screen
yeah I really enjoyed that aspect of
Doctor Strange - it sort of subverts
though yeah yeah yeah we're trying we're
trying to say okay well we're not gonna
finish like the other guys we're
destroying everything we're just gonna
go backwards we're gonna rebuild the
entire thing and at the end everything's
back to normal
and I think that was a fun twist on the
old blockbuster idea and just to go back
to IMAX for a second um what do you
think that extra top and bottom ad and
what was the process of going in and and
and making sure that it was you know
worth going to see and yeah well there's
lots of you know when you work into
furrow there's lots of work we don't do
up-and-down to be honest and here it was
like actually more work to do that but
every time we are going into sequences
that required that extra detail and
extra information at the top and bottom
we're thinking okay so what are we
putting in there and that is worthwhile
putting because you know it just it's an
interesting format that we can play with
so every time we had a sequence who are
looking at okay so we can put that oh
we're going to put that thing up there
so that the guys from IMAX can see it
only these guys can see it so it was
like finding some little clever things
or reframing shots so that we would see
more at the top and the bottom and some
more interesting information and do you
have any behind the scenes things that
we should look for when watching the
movie like is there anything that you
want to like you know hint that that we
should be on the lookout oh I don't know
well I mean you know it's every show
there's a story obviously some funny
stories some some difficult stories some
like oh my god what are we gonna do that
stories but there's too many of them for
me to get into it's yeah it's just I
don't know what you say really so do you
have any words of advice for people who
are interests
and diving in and working in VFX right
well I mean if they're interested they
should really look into trying to find
out how we do things you know there's
lots of publications and things online
where you can look at it I think the
main thing for me if you want to work in
visual effects you have to learn to be a
storyteller as well because I think it's
nowadays with visual effects we can do
pretty much everything you know
depending on the budget and the time you
have obviously but I think what makes
the difference is when you make
something that tells a story so as a
visual effects artist I think you have
to be very cautious about that and very
aware of what your your work is doing
and what your work is bringing to the
story so that's my advice so now in
terms of getting into the craft and
getting into the work you know just if
you really like that never give up never
surrender and just keep pushing you know
I'm I'm a French guy I used to live in
France and I've you know I've pushed and
pushed and pushed to to get to where I
am now and it just takes a lot of work
and a lot of effort to get there but
it's very interesting
so just never give up and go for it
how did you get into visual effects you
know because that's such a specific
that's uh that's a long long story I've
I've always used computers when I was a
kid you know my dad was an engineer and
he also had a super 8 camera so I stole
his computer and his camera and I
started to do little films with my
brothers animation films you know things
like that that's when I was a kid and
then did more and more and learned by
myself because at the time there was no
schools or anything then I did what we
call a license so it's like a bachelor
degree in physics when I was in France
in quantum mechanics and then went to an
art school and then started to work in
videogames not for too long because
that's not what I wanted to do I saw
Star Wars when I was a kid so that just
really made me think I want to do that
and I kept on wishing I started to work
on
in Paris go beef which was doing lots of
American films so that's where I started
and they moved to London and met the
guys from Marvel and work more and more
with them and now I'm in LA working with
them what's next for you I don't know
yet
but very likely a new Marvel movie do
you want to work on one of those Star
Wars films eventually uh well I've had a
question a lot when I was doing
guardians actually have you know I love
Star Wars I really love it
I think what they are doing with it is
very interesting right now but I've done
my Star Wars I've done guardians of the
galaxy so you know it's it's my own
Stowers and it was new and fresh and
different so I'm I'm glad I've done that
you know I'm not saying no but I think
I've done it so we're coming up on our
fiftieth anniversary why yeah max around
for a while now can you tell us you know
your personal experience like growing up
you know yeah having you know gone to
see I'm enemies and you know the
institutional theater yes and what you
think
IMAX now in the last you know decades
has come into the Hollywood film
business how it's changed sort of movie
going yeah well I think you know I mean
first my personal experience with Imus
was when I was a kid you know the first
I think the first big imax theater in
France was at level 8 which is a Museum
of Science in Paris which actually my
dad worked on to build as an engineer so
I had the plans of the the place at my
house when I was a kid and my dad was
talking to us about it you know and then
we went and we saw our first time acts
movie there which was pretty exciting
and I've always been super excited to
see movies in IMAX at all these museums
and things like that and then I'm very
glad actually that they moved into you
know more like proper you know movies
and everything I think it brings a lot
to the experience of going to see a
movie you know the bigger the screen the
bigger the sound the more you know the
better the experience is in my opinion
for the kind of movies were doing so I
find that very exciting
and I mean it's been 50 years Wow but uh
you know I've I'm very excited about the
technology and you know the the amount
of detail and beauty that this French
did to our film is actually very
rewarding for us so I'm very glad that
IMAX is working with Marvel now that
where we get to do these movies with you
guys do you remember the first IMAX
movie you saw I think it was I wouldn't
know that title it was something about
the space shuttle going to space
so the takeoff you know with the sound
and you could see the space shuttle and
all that the plumes of smoke and and the
old you know theater vibrating and my
ribcage kind of vibrating at the same
time so that was quite an experience as
a kid definitely if you could pick any
film mm-hmm
of all time what why do you want to see
remax in imax 2001 in imax would be cool
that's a really popular yeah
else in IMAX I think this would be this
would be the ones definitely yeah